so I'm going to talk about the financial
crisis and banking this is really not a
recession it's a reset and it's not so
much an economic crisis as a crisis of
virtues and values and one of the things
that we forgotten about is the power of
the idea that's what America would was
based on what made America great is was
made every great nation great in its
time and so we move from the power of
the idea and using free enterprise and
capitals in the spread that idea and
agreed value in society and as a result
of that should become wealthy and
powerful maybe to just be with being
focused on being wealthy and powerful
and so we've made the by product the
product we made money the product and
that's why we get a wall and that's why
I say the crisis of virtues and values
and so I think that the innovation that
people are not thinking about the day or
is really this global economic crisis is
a reset and opportunity for us to get
right again and in 20th century the
issue was democracy all around the world
and so you had movements for democracy
civil rights in the hands of the average
person the right to vote South Africa
with Nelson Mandela the southern states
in America with the dr king and my hero
and mentor ambassador Andrew Young his
aid in India you had of course Gandhi we
still have the struggle for democracy
with the Palestinians etc so in the
least but in the 21st century you got to
have a in this global economic crisis
and the backdrop for the global economic
crisis the reset the new issue of civil
rights not civil rights with silver
rights in this backdrop but you don't
have a bank account and you don't
understand the language of money
financial literacy you are in economic
slave and so we have got to make free
enterprise and capitalism work for the
poor and so I think the financial
literacy I called the language of money
of Operation Hope is the new civil
rights and civil rights issue for the
21st century opera shop is doing its
part in the US which served a million
one hundred thousand people giving them
basic tools and we're up and out of
poverty and divert and check cashing
customers and the bank
murs and renters and homeowners and
small-business reemerging the small
business owners and entrepreneurs the
guy who made the suit that I wear today
and the shirt I wear today is an
operation hope success story came in
with a thirty-five thousand dollar idea
one of the loan we gave them knowledge
instead financial literacy knowledge
help them get the loan as well through
banks vouching for his credibility he's
now doing eight hundred thousand dollars
a year in revenue as an entrepreneur and
six full-time employees is drogue
clothing brian taylor in south central
LA and is pay his taxes and raising his
children and it's a responsible citizen
and it started a non-profit to teach
young people how to be responsible
citizens called leave so he's leaping
forward paying it forward and that's
doing well in doing good so there's the
big answer here the big idea is a
massive campaign on financial literacy
around this world bank's can use this to
get their brand back to get their
reputation back the credibility back
that uses to empower people and if we do
this right will create a new generation
a new culture I guess and finally I've
saved my friend Quincy Jones since it
takes 20 years of change of culture in
the last 20 years we've made dumb sexy
we've dumb down and we've celebrated if
we do this right we'll make smart sexy
again and we will never end up for this
place again